mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonsoir vous allez voir ce soir une
émission unique enfin unique surtout
parce que parce qu'une fois vous allez
voir les meilleures séquences de toutes
les émissions que j'ai produite et
présentée depuis 1985
si vous faites le compte mais trente ans
de télé à moi c'est pour 2015
ensuite je vais pouvoir voter vous direz
voter ça sert à rien sauf que là comme à
partir de la semaine prochaine mardi
mahatma nouvelle émission on vous
demande de voter sur les images des
autres
on a pensé qu'il serait sport de vous
demander de voter sur les images à moi
alors pour voter c'est pas compliqué
vous faites le 36 65 7 1 2 3 voilà tout
au long de l'émission vous aurez les
résultats en direct soyez sympa ne soyez
pas trop dur parce que vous savez sous
le costume noir il ya un coeur qui bat
un coeur d'artichaut
[Musique]
un père mastic le plus mastoc
le plus pervers
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là
à
[Musique]
paris
mais
[Musique]
oh
oui
le vieux piano l'appelant le joug
console quand son habitude vieux pianos
d'appeler à des clients dont l'habitude
et de danser le samedi le dimanche
les autres jours salah sur les planches
dans la mer qui se souvient il rêve sont
[Musique]
je
mais la finition
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus